suite et fin de notre série consacrée
aux économies d'eau dans l'agriculture
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse au sorgho une
céréale d'avenir originaire d'Afrique et
qui résiste bien à la sécheresse notre
région et la troisième de France en
terme de surface cultivée avec 7500
hectares en 2022 alors cette petite
graine cousine du maïs va-t-elle
progressivement envahir nos champs la
réponse dans ce reportage de Sarago
sur ces 7 hectares Sébastien Prouteau
cultive du sorgho blanc une variété de
céréales exotique importée d'Afrique et
une alternative pour réduire sa surface
d'exploitation de maïs s'adapte très
très bien notre climat très peu
exigeante en eau et une forte une forte
capacité d'adaptation au
changement climatique aujourd'hui au
manque de do ou aux effets de chaleur
donc une culture qui te vend qui
s'implante très très facilement dans
notre département dans notre région
celeval de Loire une faible consommation
en eau loin d'être une négligeable il
faut compter 50 mm d'eau pour irriguer
un mètre carré de sorgho 3 fois moins
que pour le maïs avec la sécheresse ce
dernier est devenu inexploitable sur
certaines parcelles Sébastien consacre
désormais 50 hectares à la culture du
sorgho presque 1/4 du total de son
exploitation on était la première région
de France en production de de sorgho il
y a quelques temps ça a chuté nettement
parce que les conditions ont été plus
favorables à des enveloppement plus
classique je moi je pense que la le
sorgho à sa place c'est une culture qui
doit trouver sa place et qui a sa place
dans le dans le développement et puis
dans les roches alternatives et puis
aussi dans la diversité des cultures
même si le sorgho reste une alternative
aux nombreuses qualités impossible
cependant de le substituer totalement au
maïs chaque céréale possède sa propre
vertu